announcement okay oh oh please come on
guys
come on guys is it ounuma is he gonna
pop up on the no okay did he just say
this
he said this next segment is the last
announcement so
this is the zelda segment this is the
zelda segment guys i bet you i bet you
after this how numa is going to pop up
on the screen
what what is this what is this link's
just got freaking
numchucks out of guardian feet i love
that
so much yep goodbye money oh
put zelda on the bike link move over
you had the cannon appearance on the
bike now it's zelda's turn
there he is love the shirt okay wait i'm
turning this up
my heart is beating so fast you guys
grab your glass of water
i have it i have it my glass of water
are you okay i have a few more
i'm okay i'm okay okay skyward sword
first sky resort first
and then i he said a few he said a few
what else is there
what else is there i'm legit a little
bit lightheaded
next up next up okay
okay gamingwatchlink is the cutest thing
i've ever seen look at him
look at him you betcha this is going up
right right there
right back on my i'm pointing out on the
camera all right
all right something we have to show you
guys this is the sequel to the legend
oh two years have passed since we first
announced this game oh my gosh
it's time it's time it's time it's time
development has been steadily
progressing for today
we've prepared some new footage to show
a bit more it's time it's set
up okay okay
malice tendrils oh the the the arm it's
malice that gets
that grabs him
ganondorf's up he's up guys oh goodbye
zelda
oh no i thought she was gonna be
playable
whoa we're going under the surface
we're going under the surface look at
his arm
it's a new world it's under the surface
[Music]
oh my word oh my word
moving stone telus camps
the powers have made a return the chica
slate
his arm is a cannon it's exactly what we
thought the arm is a cannon
oh i'm gonna be analyzing this in just a
second
the castle's moving it's
it's it's powers it doesn't look like a
divine beast looks like i was wrong bear
though that's okay
it's malice that's making it fly just
like in ocarina of time just like an
ocarina of time just like in
ocarina
oh my gosh 2022 y'all
2022 oh i love you aunum thank you
i loved it i loved it okay i hope you'll
look forward to it
i am thank you i'm shaking i'm shaking
all right y'all i'm ending it right now
i'm ending it right now because i'm
gonna analyze that okay
i love you guys i love you guys bye okay
subscribe to the channel like it
subscribe to these guys bye